what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Kent the son of
Superman in the Injustice Universe which
is amazing now we'll make sense of
everything going on with Injustice and
especially one of the theories that you
all have which I love but this initially
opens up with Superman talking to Wonder
Woman now one of the things to know
about Wonder Woman in the Injustice
universe is she'd always kind of had a
thing for superman but the reality here
is he had always been hung up on the
death of Lois Lane and again we'll talk
about that here in a little bit because
it's one of the coolest things to happen
but the thing about this is she kind of
makes this case in saying that we don't
necessarily know what's going on with
this kid so we can't fully put our trust
in him but Superman feels a kind of
connection with Jonathan now one of the
things that happens jumping over to
Jonathan himself is he basically wakes
up in a recovery room alongside Lex
Luthor now Lex Luthor in the Injustice
universe is a little bit different than
you normally expect in the main DC
Universe because in the main DC Universe
he's a main villain of Superman right
he's just like Superman's arch nemesis
and one of the coolest villains in DC
Comics but in Injustice he falls Rank
and file with everyone body else and
it's a really cool reason as to why but
one of the things he talks about is that
where Jonathan initially sees him as
Luther and approaches him as a villain
Luther realizes pretty fast that he and
Jonathan are basically enemies on the
earth that Jonathan comes from now
that's one of the cool things that goes
on here is it seems to happen off panel
but everybody seems to come to the
realization pretty fast that Jonathan is
not from this universe and neither is
Ultraman now it's kind of a cool moment
here because as the two of them start to
talk that one of the things Luther does
is hit to this idea that Superman in
this reality has been through a lot and
he's trying his best but he seems to hit
to this idea that everything is dark
right that this version of Superman is
not the Superman that Jonathan thinks he
is which is true this version of
Superman is a dick but he's also one of
the coolest versions of Superman ever
and we'll talk about why because
Injustice is so cool so of course Luther
doesn't really finish his sentence
because Superman shows up and it's wise
for Luther not to finish that sentence
because Superman would likely kill him
if he did and so what ends up happening
is that Jonathan kind of explains Lanes
what's going on and saying that there's
a villain named Ultraman who's traveling
around the Multiverse and killing
different variants of Superman across
the entire Multiverse now again we don't
necessarily know exactly why ultraman's
doing this or at least was doing it I
mean he's dead now but we simply knew he
was doing it by way of using a device
that would basically de-power or at
least weaken any version of Carol he
came across in any other Universe hence
the reason why they grab Superman in the
first place by the way that was my
mistake in the last video I always
confuse valzad and President Calvin
President Calvin is the leader of the of
the House of Heroes and the multiversal
Justice League valzad he's the Superman
from Earth too do you guys remember that
story at the beginning of the new 52
when like the whole Justice League were
killed by Steppenwolf in like the first
issue and like issue number one but
again that's my mistake that's my error
it was Val's odd he's he's the Earth 2
Superman so the thing about this is that
you basically have The Flash come
running in right and tell them like
there's some crazy thing going on in
Star City that kind of situation we have
to respond they talk about how it has to
to basically do with Batman and so what
this does is it leads to Superman and
Wonder Woman taking off to confront
Batman and where Jonathan wants to go
along for the ride the response is no
right but then ultimately he says I
can't just stay here I have to go there
and find out what's going on and so we
transition over to Gotham City now here
is where the Theory comes into play and
I love that you guys have this idea so
we didn't really finish Injustice 2 the
follow-up to the Injustice comic but
basically Superman Was Defeated at the
end of Injustice as far as I'm aware if
I remember correctly uh he was basically
captured and locked up but like the
whole thing was effectively done here
you still have Batman and Superman
fighting against one another so the
theory that you guys have is that when
Jonathan and Ultraman travel to the
Injustice Universe they travel to the
past of the Injustice Universe because
one of the things that was solidified in
the last two issues that we covered is
that time follows the same path in every
single Universe right it's 1983 in every
Universe no matter what Universe you're
in it's 2006 it's 2023 it's always the
same so by all standards measurement
Superman should be defeated at this
point in time unless of course it's all
happening at the time that Injustice is
taking place we don't really have any
definitive answers but the fact that
Batman is still here is kind of a big
deal now this is where I want to talk
about Injustice here for a second
because this is the reason why Injustice
is so cool so the idea behind Injustice
Gods Among Us the comic book line is
that the Joker had kidnapped Lois Lane
who was pregnant with Superman's unborn
child in turn Superman and the Justice
League were trying to find her but Joker
killed scarecrow and taken some of his
fear toxin along with green Kryptonite
and a nuclear bomb come to find out when
Superman found Lois Lane in a submarine
what the Joker had done is he had laced
the fear toxin with green Kryptonite
dust so that when Superman entered into
the submarine he didn't see Lois Lane he
saw doomsday Batman who was figuring it
all out figured it out at the last
moment and really when it was too late
because Superman had basically been
pummeling doomsday and then flew
doomsday into space where doomsday was
believed to have suffocated and died
only for us to find out Superman was
tricked into killing Lois Lane and his
Unborn child not only that the Joker had
taken the nuclear bomb and basically
attached it to Lois Lane's heartbeat so
when she died Metropolis was destroyed
in a nuclear blast it was amazing like
it was one of the most crazy openings to
a story ever and then in turn Superman
just becomes this dictator right he's
like he's like enough right he kills
Joker on the spot and he was like if
you're a villain you commit a crime
you're gonna die and that's just the way
that it is right or you're gonna go to
jail there's no more of this Batman
philosophy of like I cherish my no
killing rule I don't care how many men
women and children have to die in order
for me to keep it but anybody who
commits a crime is done we covered it
you'll find a link to the Injustice
playlist down in the comments section
check it out when this video is done it
was a phenomenal story but the thing
about this is that Batman and his forces
were basically like the rebels they were
fighting against the forces of Superman
when we switched to Gotham City we pick
up with Damian Wayne the story of Damien
was really cool because what happened is
that there was a fight between the
forces of Superman and Batman and Damien
was kind of on the fence but in a fight
between himself and Nightwing he
actually ended up killing Nightwing by
accident Nightwing fell and broke his
neck because of an attack from Damian
Wayne Batman blamed Damien and then
Damien sided with Superman which he was
already kind of doing that by this point
in time but it's a really really cool
moment because when this happens you
literally have Damien confronting Batman
that's the reason why there's animosity
here between the two of them it's not
just a father and son bickering it's
Damian on the side of Superman and
Batman on the side of the rebels so of
course the two of them break out into a
fight but then Jonathan steps in and
Jonathan tries to stop the fight between
the two of them now one of the things to
remember Damien has what seems to be
enhanced strength here because it looks
like at this point in time Damien may
very well have just popped the pill that
was established in the Injustice comics
for those of you guys who don't know
that it was a pill that was developed
that could give a person the powers of
Superman hence the reason why Jonathan
points out that Damien is so much
stronger than he normally is but Damien
at this point in time because Jonathan
doesn't exist Damien doesn't see him the
same way right like Jonathan was dead it
would it was The Unborn Child of Lois
and so that's what's nuts is because in
this moment Batman's able to get away
now with Batman making his Escape you
and turn has Superman and Lois Lane who
show up here on the scene and to a
degree Jonathan kind of gets chastised
by Damien a little bit but at the same
time like you have this conversation
between Jonathan and Injustice Superman
where basically in Justice Superman lies
like he literally lies right he's like
there was a tragic accident Dick Grayson
died Bruce blamed Damien and then Damien
blamed himself too his father cast him
out and basically disowned him it's time
we talk about what happened right so
Injustice Superman comes along and says
like your mother was taken from me we
were supposed to have a child we were
supposed to have you I reacted poorly to
this I was lost for a while but in time
a new resolve Grew From my grief I
decided to do more for this world to
make this a world of less tragedy a
world where Mad Men villains and tyrants
were no longer free to harm people now
on the surface it looks like he's led
the earth into a better place he
genuinely believes that it's one of the
things to know about Injustice Superman
everything he did he did because he
believed he was doing the right thing
and you can make a moral argument where
he was Lord knows we did over the course
of Injustice right like Freedom versus
security all that kind of stuff but the
thing about this is he genuinely
believed that what he was doing was
right the reality here is that he was a
dictator man he was a fascist whether
you believe what he was doing was right
or not he became tyrannical he was like
one step away from Superman Red's son
where he basically turned everybody into
like a robot under the power of Brainiac
and basically bent the world to his whim
right like you get the end of the story
and Lex Luthor's like why don't you put
the whole world in a bottle Superman
that kind of a thing it was cool right
it was a really really cool moment in
that story but Injustice Superman
portrays everything as though he's
genuinely made the world better so in
turn Jonathan says I want to see what
the world's like but I want to do it
alone I want to do it by myself and so
he ultimately takes off now that's when
Wonder Woman meets with Injustice
Superman and asks the question do you
really think that's a good idea right he
may not necessarily approve of your
methods but the response of Injustice
Superman is maybe he won't but he will
come to the realization that the ends
justify the means that the way in which
we got to this place is fine because
there is no crime and in fact that's one
of the things that Jonathan notices
flying around in the world he says this
world is so similar to ours to the
people the places but I can feel it the
air is slightly cleaner climate change
is being reversed and if I reach out if
I let down the blocks I always have in
place I cannot hear bombs or gunfire
it's so quiet I can just hear how quiet
it is the world is quite literally a
peaceful place there's no crime or
anything but in tourney here's what
sounds like a kind of Crisis he responds
with a baby that basically fell off a
balcony he rescues it and then he flies
it back up to the mom and then the Mom
starts to panic she fills with fear but
Jonathan realizes it's not him not his
face that she's looking at it's not her
looking at him and saying oh my God
you're Superman it's horrifying it's the
symbol on his chest the S instills fear
in people now the thing about this is
this is the question that we asked right
and I'm curious for all the new fans out
there I'm curious right if Superman
becomes a dictator but it leads to a
world without crime and without violence
where people can live without having to
worry about whether or not they're going
to die so so long as they don't cross
Superman is that a good thing is it an
inherently good thing or should people
be allowed to live a life free to make
their own choices even if that means
sending the world back into a place
where it's full of chaos Madness and
death which one would you choose in this
circumstance and it's not a loaded
question that's what the world would
turn back into because that's what it
was but the thing here is that you have
this kind of discussion it's an almost
momentary thing where literally
Injustice Superman says what do you
think you can see it can't you what
we've done here the difference we've
made and that's where Jonathan observing
everything says the world is so quiet
but not because it's peaceful not
because it's free yes I can see it it's
quiet because everyone is holding their
breath because everyone is afraid to
make noise here's the question you have
to ask what happens when a fight breaks
out between Injustice Superman and
Jonathan Kent and which one's gonna come
out on top because Injustice Superman is
a hoss but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you on later
peace
[Music]